et série des gars
bienvenue sur mon blogue vidéo le lm
crio beauté beauty mas cup
chaque jour chaque semaine je vais vous
montrer des astuces des techniques super
simple à réaliser soi-même pour comment
se voir comment c'est qu'on a du glamour
comme moi eh ouais
et aujourd'hui super nouvelle des filles
on a dépassé de la barre des 10
followers
et ouais ça fait un de plus que sur le
blog vidéo de cette [ __ ] delory 75
on dirait bien que c'est la success
story
dis donc 1 alors on est trop content un
bébé bien garé en jouant fans voilà
c'est à lui donc on est tellement
content que on a décidé d'aller club et
on va plus
et ouais bébé on va te le b mais d'abord
je vais vous montrer des filles
commencent et confèrent des astuces
super simple pour ressembler à un vrai
party girl comme bilan c'est comme
commencer la chanteuse que j'aime bien
pierrick avec les cheveux longs fameux
jeu non pas l agetur bout de la langue
catherine leur nom bon c'est pas grave
en tout cas les filles qu'est ce que je
voulais vous dire aujourd'hui quand on
n'a plus 20 ans important c'est le mas
cup
et moi je vais vous donner des
techniques pour perdre pas moins de 10 à
un peu plus de dix minutes à les tutos
alors vint la base je vais rien vous
apprendre en vous disant que c'est 1 1
on peut penser masqué peu avant qu'on
n'habite pas bien fait un teint voilà
alors après tout le mas cup
qu'est ce qu'on veut on veux du fun
duclos oui du strass de paillettes et
c'est à quoi pour koné une bombe latine
s'il vous plaît c'est ça le smoking et
ce qu'est ce que je vais vous montrer
maintenant le secret du smoky eyes
première étape du secret du smoothie
nice il faut appliquer une couleur
claire au delà potière
ici et c'est ça qui va nous ouvrir le
regard du smoking
c'est ça le premier secret de smoking
deuxième secret du smoking le noir alors
allez paquet sur votre tirelire les
filles
le noir c'est du noir écoutez pas les
conneries de lloret 75 qui vous dit oui
le smoky naze il faut l'acheter d'intel
l'arc et cetera et comme par hasard on
s'aperçoit que la fille d'alain une
carte de fidélité du magasin qu'elle dit
qu'il faut un style noir connaître
moi je veux je te prendrai à dire de
plus sur mac voilà donc très
délicatement c'est ça le secret du smoky
nice c'est de l'appliquer du bord
intérieur vers le bord extérieur de
l'oeil voilà pour le smoky nice
ensuite on peut passer au phare à jour
le fera jour normalement
eh bien il faut le prendre dans une
couleur qui a un rapport avec sa couleur
naturelle alors bas pour pierrick
j'aurais dû prendre du verre ou bien du
cri mais je vous montre que moi j'aurais
fait pour moi moi ce que j'aurais fait
pour moi c'était un homme ça a quelque
chose d'un petit peu plus marqué fuchsia
voilà et après évidemment la touche
finale depuis ce qu'on va prendre c'est
du gloss quelques couches de glace par
rapport aussi avec le fard à joues qu'on
aura choisi
voilà et maintenant
tadam qui c'est qui est prête pour aller
danser au son des platines jusqu'à
presque minuit c'est moi voilà
alors le riz 75
on s'éclate comme ça non de tutos à toi
dans le monde du blog est des principes
du respect je te signale alors vas
mourir kaunas